aider selon les différentes catégories
d'attaquants et d'attaquer une erreur de
la loi via ça a été de tout mettre dans
le même panier sous le sous le nom et no
line quel rôle pour les réseaux sociaux
on a vu et big for donc les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce quelqu'un c'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à douala
des entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aucune preuve de risque aggravé de
caillots sanguins offre avec le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
le groupe pharmaceutique britannique
réagit après la suspension de
l'utilisation de son sérum dans
plusieurs pays
principe de précaution en islande au
danemark en norvège
guéri l'agencé européenne du médicament
a diligenté une enquête pas de raison de
ne pas vacciner avec les freins zeneca
rassure aussi de son côté l oms le monde
de la culture est en colère de nouvelles
aides ont été annoncés pour accompagner
les professionnels de ce secteur à
l'arrêt depuis de nombreux mois
pas suffisant ils me demandent la
réouverture des laits culturel à paris
de théâtre de l'odéon et occupé depuis
plus d'une semaine et qu'un vote la
réforme électorale de hong kong
l'assemblée nationale du peuple a clos
ses travaux ce jeudi qu'elle mettait à
exécution son projet de transformation
du code électoral au congrès seul des
patriotes pouvons désormais diriger la
région administrative
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france astrazeneca des
fonds la sûreté de son vaccin anti
qu'ovide dans un communiqué publié ce
vendredi le groupe pharmaceutique
britannique affirme qu'il n'ya aucune
preuve de risque aggravé de caillots
sanguins entraîné par son sérum les
chiffres sur ce type de problème médical
sont beaucoup plus faible chez ceux qui
sont vaccinées comparé à ce qui serait
attendu dans la population dans son
ensemble ajoute le groupe
l'agencé européenne du médicament a
lancé une enquête elle ajoute des
allergies sévères à la liste des effets
secondaires possibles mais estime que le
bénéfice de ce sérum et supérieurs à ses
risques
plusieurs pays ont décidé de suspendre
l'utilisation du vaccin anglo-suédois
par précaution le danemark la norvège
l'islande et se battant la bulgarie leur
a emboîté le pas j'ordonne
qu'astrazeneca le vaccin britannique
soit suspendue jusqu'à ce que nous ayons
une confirmation écrite de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
un avis précis et clairement confirmé
sur la question de savoir si oui ou non
il peut être utilisé d'ici là nous
l'arrêterons mais l oms veut rassurante
pas de raison selon elle de ne pas
vacciner avec l'astra zeneca oui nous
devrions continuer à utiliser le vaccin
astrazeneca
ce que nous regardons c'est ce que nous
regardons toujours c'est à dire que tout
signal de sécurité doit être examiné en
fait il est très important que nous
entendions les signaux de sécurité
car si nous n'entendions aucun signal de
sécurité cela suggérerait que la
vigilance n'est pas suffisante à les
vaccins qui n'en finissent pas de faire
débat en europe cette fois ci c'est leur
répartition au sein du lieu qui est
questionnée des divergences croissantes
selon les pays pour le chancelier
autrichien sebastian kurz accuse
certains états membres d'avoir conclu en
coulisses des contrats avec des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques il réclame
une transparence accrue il s'est exprimé
en conférence de presse dans la journée
aladine qui cependant est ce la est
apparu ces derniers jours au moment même
où ses décisions étaient prises par les
chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
un soi-disant comité directeur
composée de responsables de la santé a
conclu d'autres accords avec des
sociétés pharmaceutiques ce qui est
clairement en contradiction avec ses
décisions qui sont les contrats de cette
instance son secret est je ne les
connais donc pas moi même
mais il ya des indications selon
lesquelles il existe une instance un
d'hazard ou des accords supplémentaires
ont été conclus entre les états membres
et les firmes pharmaceutiques est la
pologne et la hongrie ion elle a saisi
hier la cour de justice de l'union
européenne sur un tout autre sujet elle
dénonce le mécanisme conditionnant les
versements de fonds européens au respect
des règles de l'état de droit dont
varsovie et budapest sont souvent
accusés d'enfreindre les principes les
deux pays qui avaient obtenu cette
clause en échange de la levée de leur
veto au plan de relance économique
ce recours judiciaires leur permet de
gagner du temps elle une telle procédure
dure en moyenne un an et demi rappelle
nicolas mirkovic analystes et politique
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que l
union européenne c'est un peu les états
unis d'europe comme on a les états unis
d'amérique et que la pologne la hongrie
illégalement la france ou l'espagne
elle vient sont des états comme le sens
états unis le wyoming la californie et
que si un gouvernement fédéral qui est
au dessus de tout ça il peut décider qui
a le droit ou pas de recevoir des
subventions des aides quelles sont les
issues
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas trop déjà
savoir que l'instruction de ces plaintes
durer un à un à deux ans comme ça prend
beaucoup de temps
est-ce que l'union européenne osera
aller jusqu'à exclure des pays qui ne
respectent pas le ce que le laquelle
l'état d'autres pensent qu'ils vont voir
ce que doit posséder fille comme état de
droit ça m'étonnerait en revanche le
mécanisme actuel de distribution de
l'aide
et on parle plus de 700 milliards et
abus et un budget de 2021 2022 de 2000
milliards d'euros est bloqué en italie
face à une nouvelle vague de contagion
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le premier
ministre italien mario draghi lors d'un
déplacement dans un centre de
vaccination près de rome le nom
elle contamination dans le pays a grimpé
hier à près de 25000 ainsi sans
conséquence
l'italie sera en grande partie confiné
dès lundi avec une fermeture des
restaurants des bars et des écoles les
régions les plus peuplées notamment la
lombardie poumon économique du pays et
la région de rome seront classées en
rouge les déplacements ils seront à
limiter aux impératifs de travail à
l'achat de produits de première
nécessité aux urgences de santé pour le
week-end de pâques c'est toute la
péninsule qui sera d'office en rouge
une façon d'éviter les rassemblements
familiaux et festif
la france peut-elle compter sur un an
quatrième vaccin les autorités
sanitaires viennent de valider le sérum
de johnson and johnson l'hexagone qui
pour la première fois depuis fin
novembre compte plus de 4000 patients en
réanimation
l'île de france en particulier suscite
l'inquiétude
les variants du coronavirus y circule
activement des transferts de patients
vers d'autres régions pour éviter la
saturation des hôpitaux sont prévues
mais pas de confinement envisagée pour
l'heure car jean castex dit prêt à
prendre des mesures
il était en déplacement en fin de
journée chez à l'hôpital parisien de la
pitié-salpêtrière de ce week-end nous
allons en ile de france justement
accéléré comme on l'a fait le week-end
dernier la vaccination n'a délégué 25
mille doses supplémentaires pour cette
région
l'objectif évidemment c'est de le
soulager d'arriver à soulager le système
hospitalier et je le répète nous devons
également nous tenir prêts parce que la
situation est très préoccupante a aucun
engagement sur le renouvellement de
l'assurance chômage mais le gouvernement
dit vouloir assurer les prestations
maladie des intermittents 20 millions
d'euros vont également être débloqués
pour les artistes débutants ou petite
troupe de musique de danse ou de théâtre
privé de recettes
pas suffisant pour calmer la colère des
professionnels de la culture ils
demandent la réouverture des lieux
culturels
voilà plus d'une semaine que plusieurs
dizaines d'entre eux occupent peut-être
parisien de l'odéon
un nouveau rassemblement était organisé
cet après midi notre reporter katia
techniques étaient sur place
ici au théâtre de l'odéon l'occupation
dure depuis huit jours
une agora aujourd'hui pour s'élever
contre la réforme de l'assurance chômage
et là je me trouve avec l'un des
occupants mathieu qui est musicien
bonjour mathieu alors vous êtes venus
depuis le début voit ici oui je voulais
arriver donc il ya une semaine jeudi
dernier mois je suis arrivé avec la
première équipe je suis musicien donc on
a rentré le matériel de musique puisque
c'est quand même une
c'est une occupation revendicatives mais
quand même joyeuse alors ok qu'est ce
qui a présidé à votre envie de d'occuper
ce théâtre bon c'est à dire on a des
problèmes dans le champ culturel on a
des revendications dans le champ
culturel donc la prolongation des droits
des intermittences qu'on est ce qu'ils
ont appelé l'année blanche
on demande à fond pour pour travailler
pour avoir le moyen de payer des
répétitions pour financer on demande des
mesures pour les pour les primo entrants
les nouveaux entrants les femmes
les femmes enceintes et les arrêts
maladie on demande l'ouverture des lieux
et puis à tout ça évidemment s'ajoute la
réforme de l'assurance-chômage
l'annulation de la réforme d'assurance
chômage parce que c'est quand même un
point hyper centrales dans le monde dans
lequel on vit en ce moment vous avez
beaucoup de revendications pour des
droits ce qui veut dire que en ce moment
là vous nous le confirmer la profession
est sinistré et beaucoup de vos amis et
de la culture sont dans des situations
économiques très difficiles
bah ouais nous nous sommes enfin on peut
plus travailler les lieux sont fermés on
en a pas fais moi j'ai pas fait beaucoup
de concerts de l'hiver quasiment aucun
en fait quoi et donc du coup ses traits
fins vollard non pour nous c'est très
très très compliqué de travailler en ce
moment les lieux sont fermés que ce soit
dans dans les salles de spectacle ou
voilà les cinémas sont fermés les bars
les restaurants sont fermés c'est des
lieux aussi où on travaille pas mal
l'événementiel est à l'arrêt il ya tous
les tous les secteurs d'activité où on
peut travailler faire de la musique des
concerts ou des spectacles tout est à
l'arrêt c'est très très compliqué pas
comment vous vous organiser ici pour
justement résister militer pas que cette
occupation soit réussie que vous
obteniez des choses est bas alors mois
pour obtenir des choses on occupe on est
vous êtes vous savez on a il ya
maintenant environ 20 lieux qui sont
occupées donc on est il ya l'odéon il ya
ce qu'on fait ici ce qu'on a fait ici
est ce qu'on aura pulse et puis il ya
près de maintenant tous les lieux
occupés ou voilà le les luttes se
produisent et tout ça donc
mais ici au bon voilà c'est des espaces
ouverts on occupe ici nous centre
névralgique de l'occupation y tient on a
monté le matériel de musique là derrière
on fait des concerts tous les soirs il
ya des âges et les ag ont lieu ici on
non il ya 2
les lieux où l'on mange sont plutôt là
haut voilà on envahit vachement à
à respecter les gestes barrière à porter
tout ceux masqués à faire attention à
tout ça quoi
et vous avez l'intention de rester
jusqu'à quand danse théâtre
si c'est pas moi qu'il faut poser la
question il faut que vous alliez voir
jean castex roselyne bachelot emmanuel
macron chercher on a du mal à savoir qui
décide et qui fait quoi parce que pour
tout vous dire c'est pas très clair mais
c'est d'eux que ça dépend nous nous on a
des revendications de monde à ce qu'elle
soit satisfaite si elles sont
satisfaites de man je pense qu'on je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour
entrer chez nous et puis et puis je
retravaille et enfin nous c'est ce qu'on
veut et nous sommes en direct avec eric
labbé cofondateur de maisons message une
agence de relations presse et
communication dédiée à la culture
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce soir vous êtes signataires
d'une tribune parue ce jeudi dans
libération qui pointe du doigt je sais
que la politique bipolaire du
gouvernement expliquait notamment de
quatre mois on est dans une vie qui est
scindée en deux et quasiment normalement
la journée on vit avec un travail
beaucoup moins de télétravail que qu'au
début on vit avec des transports on vit
avec des commerces on vit avec les
écoles qui sont là on a une vie qui est
complètement normal en journée et par
part pour le soir le week end on a une
vie sociale et culturelle qui est
complètement la reine ne voit plus les
gens on ne va plus au théâtre et au
cinéma on ne prend plus le temps de se
décompresser et c'est cet état de fait
qui peut être acceptable
pendant quelques semaines là ça fait pas
loin de quatre mois et il s'agirait tac
c'est toujours comme ça pendant l'été
les clés quel protocole sanitaire ont
été mises en place pour accueillir dans
les lieux culturels c'est devait rouvrir
ces prochaines semaines
il ya des protocoles qui sont
relativement bien établie depuis un
certain temps dans l'est pour tout ce
qui est spectacle assis pour le
spectacle acide au théâtre et le cinéma
des protocoles qui marche bien elle
aucun cluster dans un cinéma revenant
hanter là bas ça marche bien on peut
encore les renforcer on peut encore
imaginer
gratté par ci par là une place entre
deux où je ne sais pas quoi faut limiter
les interactions avant et après les
séances c'est un des trucs importants
donc il ya des choses qu'on peut faire
pour éventuellement renforcer ces
protocoles mais la base les protocoles
existe pour les musées c'est encore plus
grossier pour le musée il n'y a pas un
médecin qui ne vous disent qu'il n'y a
aucun problème pour visiter des musées
aujourd'hui toutes les conditions sont
respectées il ya évidemment aucun souci
et même pour le pour le l'extérieur pour
les événements extérieurs même en deux
bouts avec la manière dont le don
l'extérieur réduit les probabilités de
deux comptes domination on peut
complètement avoir des protocoles qui
tienne la route dès demain offert des
événements et alors comment est ce que
vous expliquer la réticence du
gouvernement à rouvrir ces lieux
culturels comment est-ce qu'il se
justifie auprès de vos acteurs du monde
de la culture pour l'instant fait de
tout ce passe comme si ils avaient
décidé que toute la toupie tout l'effort
doit être portée par les activités
sociales et culturelles
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas d'autres
gouvernements en europe qui fait ce
choix là c'est à dire que on a vu en
allemagne en angleterre ils ont fait
baisser drastiquement les niveaux de
contamination
on est aujourd'hui en dessous de dix
mille carats quotidien on a le maniement
d'angleterre alors qu'on est à 25 ou 30
ans n'en vends france parce que on a
tout arrêté
c'est en arrêtant tout pendant une durée
réduite de six semaines quatre semaines
six semaines qu'on arrive à vraiment
baisser les taux là ce qu'on a fait
c'est un espèce d'entre eux on a dit
voilà la vie professionnelle productive
la consommation ça fonctionne comme
d'habitude mais en revanche tout ce qui
est social et culturel on l'arrête
on voit bien que ça des conséquences
psychologiques et psychiatriques très
lourde le nombre de députés défensif
chez les jeunes a doublé non en revanche
il ya aucune raison de penser que ça va
ça va suffire puisque puisqu'on voit
bien que ça ne marche pas ça ne marche
pas c est qu on ne réduit pas qu'à
l'exception culturelle française vous
semble vous semble vide de sens
aujourd'hui comparé à ces pays notamment
européens que vous citez qui ont
maintenu leur lieu culturel ouvert
c'est presque une exception culturelle
française à lons
on est dans une année sans doute
aujourd'hui le pays qu'a fait la plus
grande différenciation entre ce qu'ils
considèrent ce que le gouvernement
considère comme essentiel et ce qu'il
considère comme non essentiels à
d'autres pays en europe ou dans le monde
qui est chez telle distinction
quel regard que vous portez sur le
mouvement d'occupation des théâtres
c'est là la meilleure façon peut-être la
seule de sarran tendre aujourd'hui da
par les autorités c'est pas la seule des
tribunaux s'il veut une autre manière de
le cher mais aujourd'hui je pense que on
à l'illustration que les acteurs de la
culture sont vraiment vraiment vraiment
en demande d'un d'un truc qui bouge toi
mais je pense que le lounge de l'espèce
de statu quo sont maintenant très très
long qu'on connaisse il y plus je suis
pour faire des îles et roselyne bachelot
jean tordeur quand ce matin ses
déclarations c'est plus possible de dire
quand les gens qui souffrent c'est plus
ça dont on a besoin n'a plus besoin de
compassion interdisant on a besoin de
toutes nos décisions aux politiques
fortes
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne eric labbé cofondateur de la
maison message et on parle en poche il y
très bon élève en matière de vaccination
plus 4 millions 108 ch il y en déjà reçu
une première dose antico vide et le pays
ambitionne de vacciner 80 % de ses 19
millions d'habitants d'ici au mois de
juillet quand un voeckler une
vaccination à la chaîne qui place le
chili dans les premiers rangs mondiaux
le pays d'amérique latine a déjà injecté
au moins une dose de vaccin à 5,72
millions de personnes soit environ 30 %
de sa population et cette campagne de
vaccination ne cesse de s'accélérer ce
mercredi les autorités recensaient 1,3
dose administrée pour 100 habitants
premier ratio au monde devant notamment
israël des émirats arabes unis et le
royaume uni
aujourd'hui pour la première fois et
c'est une chose a souligné le chili est
le premier pays au monde pour le rythme
de la vaccination
le classement publié chaque jour montre
que le chili est le premier au monde au
dessus d'israël pas épargné par la
pandémie avec plus de 21 mille morts
depuis l'apparition du virus sur son
territoire de chibia réussi à
s'approvisionner en vaccins dès le début
de l'année 2000 21 6 21 mille doses du
vaccin files heures ont été injectés en
décembre c'est grâce à l'arrivée de 4
millions de doses du sérum du chinois
sinovac que la vaccination chilienne
s'est accéléré lundi dernier plus de 2
millions de doses supplémentaires de ce
vaccin sont arrivés à l'aéroport de
santiago
le contrat avec sinovac comprend une
option pour 60 millions de doses en
trois ans sur cette option c'est à dire
sur les 20 millions de doses prévues
pour 2021
notre pays a déjà opté pour 14 millions
de doses dont 10 millions sont déjà
arrivés au chili et pour les quatre
autres millions dont nous avons convenu
dans le contrat
nous nous attendons à ce qu'elle arrive
d'ici la fin du mois
en plus du contrat avec sinovac
le chili multiplie les contacts avec
d'autres groupes pharmaceutiques pour
acquérir plus de doses de vaccins 4
millions de doses ont ainsi été
commandés auprès d'astrazeneca
mais aussi auprès de l'américain johnson
& johnson
le chili a également intégré le
dispositif onusien kovacs le chili
bénéficié de deux facteurs importants
tout d'abord je suis sûr qu'ils avaient
une bonne planification et qui l'a
judicieusement utilisé les ressources
dont il dispose pour conclure des
accords bilatéraux avec certains
producteurs de vaccins de plus le chili
participe également à kovacs ce qui
signifie qu'il a maintenu de multiples
options pour avoir accès au vaccin
grâce à la réussite de leurs campagnes
de vaccination les autorités chiliennes
peuvent se permettre de venir en aide à
leurs voisins
le chili a récemment fait don de 20
mille doses du vaccin de sinovac au
paraguay ainsi qu'à l'équateur aux états
unis joe biden est en passe de gagner
son pari
au lendemain de sa victoire à la
présidentielle il avait promis de faire
de la lutte contre la pandémie sa
priorité
aujourd'hui 60 millions d'américains ont
déjà été vaccinées il devrait donc
pouvoir se réunir lors de la fête
nationale du 4 juillet c'est la bonne
nouvelle annoncée par le président
américain en direct à la télévision
le 4 juillet il ya de fortes chances que
vos familles et vos amis ici pour réunir
dans votre jardin ou dans votre quartier
pour faire un barbecue essais libres et
la quête de l'indépendance
cela ne signifie pas qu'il y aura de
grands événements avec beaucoup de gens
réunis
mais cela signifie que du petit groupe
iront se réunir ce n'est pas le moment
de relâcher la pression
comme nous sortons d'un hiver sombre
pour entrer dans un printemps et un été
plein d'espoir ce n'est pas le moment de
ne pas respecter les règles joe biden
qui a dévoilé son plan de paix pour
l'afghanistan ils poussent à des
discussions entre kaboul et les talibans
tout en menaçant de retirer les forces
américaines pour forcer le gouvernement
afghan à négocier la russie s'est dite
elle favorable à une coalition au
pouvoir
incluant les talibans explication medias
kéfi diriger l'afghanistan avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes pour
avancer vers la paix ce vendredi la
porte parole de la diplomatie russe a
mis en avant l'option d'un gouvernement
de coalition incluant les talibans un
pouvoir provisoire en attendant un
accord de paix définitif
avec un souhait de la part de moscou un
tel projet doit émaner des afghans eux
mêmes la formation d'un gouvernement
charest soir de coalition doit être
effectuée par les afghans eux mêmes
lors des négociations sur la
réconciliation nationale vous connaissez
notre position sur ce sujet cependant
nous avons noté que la formation d'un
gouvernement inclusif serait une
solution logique au problème de
l'intégration des talibans dans la vie
politique du pays
mais encore une fois il ne fait aucun
doute que cette question doit être
réglée par les afghans eux mêmes lors
des négociations afghane une déclaration
qui intervient moins d'une semaine avant
une réunion capitale à moscou une
entrevue à laquelle doivent participer
les autorités de kaboul et des talibans
ainsi que la chine le pakistan et les
états unis
objectif de cette session trouver une
issue pacifique à la crise en
afghanistan la semaine dernière joe
biden avait aussi tenté de relancer le
processus de paix entre les dirigeants
afghans actuelle et le mouvement
islamiste
washington avait notamment appelé à une
période de réduction de la violence de
trois mois pour relancer les discussions
entre les parties concernées des
propositions pas forcément vu d'un bon
oeil par le pouvoir en place
alors que les états unis pourraient
retirer leurs troupes d'ici le 1er mai
conformément à l'accord signé l'année
dernière par donald trump
d'autres discussions autour de la paix
en afghanistan sont prévues au mois
d'avril à istanbul après la loi sur la
sécurité nationale pékin met en place
une réforme électorale a hong kong le
parlement chinois a validé ce jeudi un
projet de loi permettant à l'exécutif de
sélectionner les candidats aux élections
législatives hongkongaise une nouvelle
loi justifiée par le chaos selon les
termes employés
le chaos qui s'est emparé de la
métropole financière lors des grandes
manifestations contre l'exécutif
pro-pékin en 2019
clément hospital une mesure coup de
poing ces mots de zonza homing du bureau
des affaires de hong kong et de macao
évoque l'autonomie en kongaise le
parlement chinois a adopté à la
quasi-unanimité une réforme du système
électoral de la région autonome
celle-ci autoriserait pékin a
sélectionné les candidats aux élections
législatives à hong kong et lui
permettrait ainsi d'écarter les
candidats défavorable au gouvernement
centre
chinois bon nombre d'entre eux avaient
remporté en grande partie l'élection des
conseillers de district en 2019 ces
dernières années le chaos dans la
société hongkongaise a montré qu'il y
avait des failles et des lacunes
manifestes dans le système électoral y
compris la méthode de sélection du chef
de l'exécutif et du conseil législatif
en particulier le manque de sécurité du
scrutin a permis aux éléments anti
chinois qui ont perturbé hong kong de
faire partie des organes politiques et
d'autres structures de gouvernance de la
région administrative spéciale de
l'étranger beaucoup dénoncent une
atteinte significative au statut semi
autonome de la région administrative
un principe garanti par la déclarations
sino britannique publiée lors de la
rétrocession du territoire en 1997
la décision prise aujourd'hui constitue
une nouvelle violation du principe un
pays deux systèmes
l'union européenne va envisager la
possibilité d'adopter des mesures
supplémentaires
ces actes prive les hong kong et d'avoir
leur mot à dire sur leur propre
gouvernance en limitant la participation
politique en réduisant la représentation
démocratique tout en étouffant le débat
politique
pékin rejette formellement les critiques
formulées par bruxelles et washington
qui appelle à des élections législatives
transparentes en septembre prochain
la chine qui assure ne vouloir faire
aucune concession face à ces puissances
qui selon elle vise à déstabiliser hong
kong en 2019
un premier projet de loi sur la sécurité
nationale avait secoué la région
autonome
celui ci autorise pékin au nom de la
sûreté à intervenir dans le système
juridique hong kong et un amendement qui
avait poussé de nombreux citoyens
descendent dans la rue
qu'un économiste et spécialiste de la
chine jean paul chang est revenu sur
notre antenne sur cette nouvelle loi
écouter pékin considère que bombardant
la politique d' un pays deux systèmes il
ya aussi un pays il est pas question que
vous qu'on devienne une base d'activités
de contestation de subversion contre
l'état chinois
ceci dit la presse de pékin
ironise en même temps sur le fait que
les états unis la chambre et au
printemps est en train de passer aussi
toute une série de lois sur les
élections aux états unis et que quand il
ya les mtow quand les émeutiers sont
qualifiés des démocrates alors que quand
il disait métier washington ils sont
considérés comme des bandits voilà donc
pékin en tout cas entend faire passer le
message comme quoi ça condé a remis ça
nous regarde plus et de toute façon vous
pouvez toujours gesticule et messara
aucun effet sur la suite des événements
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
point sur la touche à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
on
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara